Today’s video has been made possible by
Wondrium, an online learning platform with
thousands of courses, lectures and documentaries
stick around until the end to find out more.
Cryptids are undoubtedly some of my favourite
creatures from folklore, having already covered
the likes of the Mothman, the Jersey Devil,
the chupacabra and the loch ness monster it’s
about time we return to North America, home
to hundreds hundreds of unique and strange creatures.
What better place to start than with none
other than Bigfoot, a creature that is said
to roam the forests of the United states and
Canada.
Bigfoot is also referred to as sasquatch and
the most common description is a large hairy
ape-like or humanoid creature that stands
anywhere between 6 to 10 feet tall.
The name bigfoot originates from a group of
men working for a logging company out of California in 1958.
During several jobs they noticed heavy equipment
and material being moved around, once they
established it was none of them they assumed
it was some kind of prank.
A man called Jerry Crew came across a set
of 16inch footprints that he thought were
human, the rest of the workers began to see
these footprints and assumed they belonged to this mysterious prankster.
They started calling this mysterious figure
Bigfoot, eventually their story as well as
a cast of the footprint would appear in a
local newspaper and thus the legend of bigfoot was born.
Mentions and depictions of creatures similar
to bigfoot go back centuries and can be traced
back to several native American tribes.
Those native to California carved images of
wild and hairy men that are now compared to the modern idea of bigfoot.
Many Alleged sightings often occur in north
west America but spread across the entirety
of North America especially in rocky and forest
dense areas like the Great Lakes region.
Most of these claims are explained as hoaxes
or animals such as large bears being mistaken for bigfoot.
Those who claim to have seen bigfoot describe
a range of varying behaviour, from throwing
rocks and branches at people, Hanging the
bones of animals from trees to mark said territory
and of course chasing those pesky trespassers
away.
The majority of these sightings happen when
it’s dark which naturally makes bigfoot
even harder to identify but have also led
to the idea that bigfoot is a nocturnal creature.
Stories from indigenous tribes speak of these
figures as something to be feared but also
respected, they aren’t malicious or malevolent.
We do see this with many stories surrounding
bigfoot; it's often him defending his territory
as opposed to him going out of his way to
attack someone.
Despite all the hysteria, the hoaxes.
the sceptics and alleged sightings, we are
no closer to finding bigfoot, but one thing is for sure.
There is no shortage of people willing to
continue this search and who knows maybe one day they may find what they’re looking for.
We find ourselves back in West Virginia this
time taking a look at the devil dogs, also
known as the white things and Sheepsquatch.
Most reported sightings of these creatures
happen around the southern counties of west virginia.
their appearance varies from Demonic dogs
to something that is more akin to a Yeti or Sasquatch that crawls on all fours.
Commonly they are described as a creature
the size of a bear with white fur, a long pointed head and saber-like teeth.
Much like the Mothman they are also thought
to have come from the TNT area in mason county
Those who claim to have been attacked say
that if felt as real as anything they had experienced before,
they felt the fangs and claws tearing into their flesh
but when the attack was over and they looked down there were no marks, no blood and nothing to even suggest they have been attacked in the first
place.
The first reported sighting of the white things
came in 1973 with a family were driving by
point pleasant, the seven year old boy in
the back told his parents he saw something
with thick shaggy white hair that was about
three feet wide.
The family then said the creature appeared
right beside their car floating in the air
following them for several minutes before
disappearing.
Sightings continued over the years along the
roadside but mostly in heavily wooded areas.
The last recorded encounter was in 2015 when
six campers came across something on top of a hill at around midnight.
Shining their torches in its direction they
revealed a creature over nine feet tall that
was charging down the hill, the only thing
separating them was a small river.
The creature stalked around for several minutes
looking for a way across but when it couldn’t
find one it jumped in and began to swim across.
The group ran back to their camp, gathered
their belongings and fled.
They reported it to the locals but not the
authorities for fear of not being believed,
it does just sound like a story made up by
kids high on shrooms in the forest.
For the next creature we head to Maumee Valley
in Northern Indiana where we find the Beast
of Busco, an enormous snapping turtle.
This story begins in 1898 in a small Indiana
town known as Churubusco or Busco for short.
A farmer named Oscar Fulk came across a giant
turtle living in a lake on his farm, he told
others in the town but no one would take him
seriously and so he decided against pursuing the turtle any further.
50 years later two locals reported seeing
a turtle that must have weighed close to 500
pounds whilst they were out fishing in what
had become known as Fulk lake.
The owner of the farm at the time had also
reported seeing the giant turtle and as word
began to spread sightings became more common.
The story became national news and groups
of curious people visited the town in hopes of seeing the monster turtle.
For a town of just over a thousand people
this had a pretty big impact, the amount of
people driving to the farm caused so much
traffic the state police were called in to offer assistance.
Those who came to see the turtle were extremely
disappointed and questioned whether it was
just a clever ploy by the then owner Gale
Harris to drive tourism to the town and his farm.
In an effort to clear his name Harris had
most of the lake drained but the turtle nicknamed
Oscar after the original farm owner was nowhere
to be seen.
Several attempts to find him may have also
been unsuccessful but the town still likes
to remember Oscar as every June they hold
a festival in his memory.
A giant turtle in all honesty isn’t that
weird but the same can’t be said for Ohio
frogman also known as the Loveland frog and
the Loveland lizard.
This cryptid is described as a 4ft tall frog
that has been seen all around Loveland Ohio.
This legend began in 1955 when a man walking
by the road reported seeing three frog-like men with webbed feet and hands.
This could have been easily brushed off as
just another drunk but reported sightings continued.
Whilst driving at 3,30 am a man noticed three
reptilian creatures by the side of the road.
At first he thought they were humans in costumes
but then he noticed they had leathery skin like a frog.
It gets stranger because one of them held
up what he called a wand and when sparks began
to shoot out he quickly drove away.
Could this wand have been a firework being
held by someone in a costume?
Possibly but I’d like to believe this man
saw three giant frog wizards practicing magic on the roadside at 3 in morning.
Interest in the Frogmen peaked once again
when the Loveland police, themselves almost
killed an animal that matched its description.
In 1972 officer Ray Shockey was driving when
an animal ran across his vehicle, ahead of
him he described a creature that was between
3 to 4 feet tall and between 50 to 75 pounds.
He said it was crouched like a frog and eventually
stood up on two feet to climb over the guard rail and head back down to the river.
Two weeks later officer Mark Mathews reported
seeing the same unidentified animal along the same roadside.
Mathews pulled out his rifle and shot the
animal dead.
Upon examining the corpses he identified it
as a large Iguana that had a missing tail
which is why both men struggled to recognize
it in the first place.
We’re going back to West Virginia and the
town of flatwoods in Braxton county for our
next cryptid, the flatwoods monster also known
as the Braxton county monster.
This cryptid is said to be 10feet tall and
4 feet wide, it has a red face, a pointed hood and a dark metallic body.
It was first seen in 1952 by three young boys
who witnessed a bright object fly across the
sky and crash on the land of a local farmer.
They told a woman named Kathleen May what
they had seen, she and three of the local boys visited the farm to see if the story
was true.
They reached the top of the hill where the
boys said the object had landed and ahead of them was a pulsating red light.
When they pointed their flashlights in it’s
direction they saw a tall man with a round face and a pointed hood.
Kathleen describes the monster as having small
claw or toy-like hands, a pointed hood and a head that resembles the ace of spades.
One of the boys said its eyes emitted a green
light and had a dark green body.
After looking for a few seconds the creature
began to move, it made a hissing noise as it glided towards them.
As it got closer all of them recalled an extremely
pungent smell, a thick mist that burnt their eyes and nose.
They panicked and ran away before they could
see the creature up close.
The sheriff and his deputy had been investigating
reports of an aircraft that had crashed but
when they visited the area the morning after
they couldn’t see or smell anything.
There were several investigations carried
out and what happened that night has been
explained in numerous ways, the bright light
in the sky was most likely a meteor.
The pulsating red light could have been an
aircraft hazard beacon and the creature with
the glowing eyes and small claws could have
just been an owl.
This still hasn’t stopped people from claiming
they’ve seen the flatwoods monster as well experiencing the smell for themselves.
If you have enjoyed this video and you’d
like to see more videos on cryptids from North America then let me know in the comments below.
As we mentioned earlier today's video has
been sponsored by Wondrium, you may have heard
me mention the great course plus, they’ve
now teamed up to create Wondrium an even bigger, better and immersive educational experience.
Wondrium aims to answer questions you never
even knew needed asking, they have all the
same great courses plus content but with even
more of a selection to choose from now.
Along with Lectures and courses there are
long and short form videos, tutorial, how
tos, travelogues and all sorts of interesting
and engaging documentaries.
With Halloween rapidly approaching I found
myself watching the three part series Monsters
Within, which covers the psychology behind
why horror films are so popular.
It also takes a look at Victorian horror novels
such as Dorian Grey and Dr Jekyll and their influences on the genre.
It is a great watch for anyone who enjoys
horror.
If you’d like try Wondrium for yourself
then visit wondrium.com/Mythology to start your free trial today.